[Musica]
alcuni anni fa era Washington per una
conferenza
avevo liberato due ore per un incontro
di piacere non con una persona
ma con un dipinto un dipinto che il
degeneres è il
generico Canottieri che sta alla Philips
collection di Washington e in cui ho
passato circa un'ora a contemplare e
analizzare il dipinto poi ho passato
diversi anni per capire il perché di
quell'incantamento cos'è che mi
avviluppava a quel dipinto E allora
quello che vi racconterò ora è un
percorso
per capire che effetti può avere l'arte
su di noi e sul modo con cui noi
possiamo imparare a guardare il mondo in
modo nuovo
ed ecco i nostri selfie che mi sono
fatto con le decine di Canottieri perché
era il mio idolo e quindi come tutti noi
facciamo anche il selfie con i nostri
idoli
bene allora
Questa è una immagine di un'osteria
dell'Ottocento a Posillipo a Napoli e
qui si vede con grande chiarezza diciamo
una tranquilla giornata estiva con un
cielo azzurro il mare blu un atmosfera
tranquilla quel caldo un po' indolente è
sicuramente molto confortevole per me
particolarmente confortevole perché non
c'è né asfalto non c'è né plastica e non
c'è neanche la fritta dei tempi moderni
ben diversa e quest'altra immagine
Questa immagine è di un futurista Gino
Severini
E questa immagine richiede un impegno
maggiore per essere compreso non
possiamo diciamo comprenderla con un
Colpo d'occhio Così come abbiamo fatto
per quell'immagine della Taverna di
Posillipo per fare per comprendere
questa immagine bisogna impegnarsi e
bisogna fare un particolare
sforzo cognitivo perché bisogna
osservarla nel suo insieme però poi
bisogna andare nei particolari cercare
di comprendere la molteplicità di questi
frammenti Cosa significano E allora
scavando e osservandosi ci vede che ci
sta alcuni frammenti che diventano un
volto con un uomo con un turbante con un
cilindro Sì una donna con
bionda poi si in giù si vede una scarpa
e andando avanti indietro si comprende
Che cos'è questo questo In realtà
sono i frammenti le varie sensazioni che
noi vediamo quando volteggiamo
furiosamente in un Valzer o in una polka
e se veniva accolto questi frammenti
dell'esperienza visiva
questo per me è una bella metafora della
complessità
perché la complessità Che cos'è come
sensazione è sostanzialmente la stessa
sensazione che proviamo nel visitare un
territorio sconosciuto una città
sconosciuta Come il pittore qui
Torres Garcia nella New York New York
degli anni 20 ci sono immagini suoni
movimento
scritte tutto appare frammentato è
difficile ricomporre un quadro d'insieme
Eppure diciamo una struttura sotto che
fa che genera tutto questo dinamismo ci
sta bisogna scoprirlo e però in noi Noi
abbiamo una doppia sensazione da una
parte
sentiamo l'ansia di stare in una
situazione che non comprendiamo da una
parte ci sta anche la curiosità e il
desiderio di comprendere bene queste
sensazioni sono soltanto gli effetti
collaterali di qualcosa di più profondo
perché la complessità è un po' come il
futuro che Si annuncia e che entra in
conflitto con le abitudini del passato
che Perché i nostri abitudini di
pensieri di comportamento non riescono a
comprendere il futuro che Si annuncia
attraverso la nostra esperienza del
mondo e allora per fare questo Noi
dobbiamo sviluppare una certa abilità
un'abilità di immaginare uno di noi Ecco
l'uomo Sapiens C3 30.000 e i 40.000 anni
fa hanno trovato una soluzione la
soluzione è utilizzare l'arte
l'arte
la musica la danza e anche le arti
figurative poi verrà il teatro Poi oggi
il cinema verranno tutte le altre forme
artistiche
perché l'arte diventa importante e
decisiva per l'uomo Sapiens perché non
ne possiamo fare a meno perché l'arte
sostanzialmente ci consente di
fare degli esperimenti mentali e una è
una
esperienza rafforzata intensificata che
ci permette di cogliere
delle cose nuove anche in maniera
intuitiva
emozionale e di farle nostre e quindi
quando noi curiamo un'opera d'arte
facciamo un po' quello che si chiama
reversingineering cioè
utilizziamo
quelle opere d'arte quelle strategie
compositive che gli artisti hanno
utilizzato per dare forma
all'opera d'arte e le riscopriamo come
abilità cognitive perché questa hanno la
carta Gli artisti hanno questa grande
capacità di
approfondire entrare dentro ai nostri
abilità profonde e trasformarle in delle
modalità di composizione dell'opera
d'arte e qui ora vi mostrerò alcune di
queste di queste
diciamo strategie compositive Cominciamo
con quelle che ci permettono di guardare
l'unità dell'esperienza la prima
sicuramente è quello di sottrarre i
dettagli se osservate questo guarda di
Turner di un vapore in tempesta voi non
notate niente nel vapore né nessun'altra
elemento stabile però se vi immergete In
questo quadro vedete in questa mancanza
di confini vi costringe di guardare
l'insieme e quindi vedete il turbinio
della tempesta che travolge gli elementi
della natura il mare e travolge anche
quella macchia nera che dovrebbe essere
il vapore in tempesta ecco questa è una
strategia di sottrarre i dettagli
utilizziamo normalmente quando facciamo
i riassunti di esperienze passate oltre
a sud di un libro i dettagli non ci
interessano più dobbiamo dare il quadro
d'insieme è un esempio di strategia
cognitiva di abilità cognitiva per
cogliere l'unità dell'esperienza una
seconda creare
simmetrie come fa Lorenzo Lotto in
questo quadro che sta a Bergamo che
rappresenta la una Madonna che viene
venerata da alcuni Santi se vedete come
usa se evidentemente la simmetria
Lorenzo Lotto se il vostro sguardo anche
se valga la perdita del quadro non può
fare a meno di tornare al centro il
centro che è appunto la Madonna questa
idea della simmetria Noi la conosciamo
noi la utilizziamo continuamente
negli ambiti dei discorsi e delle
attività in cui sono in gioco l'equità
la giustizia
il bilanciamento dei poteri
bilanciamento delle posizioni per noi è
un modo per comporre La diversità in un
insieme attraverso questi concetti di
equità
terzo terza strategia
l'unità dell'esperienza un e questo la
vediamo
la strategia del raggruppamento Questa è
la controfacciata della Cappella degli
Scrovegni dipinte da Giotto Voi vedete
che Giotto per dare un po' di ordine a
questo giudizio universale dove ci sono
tanti personaggi li classifica i santi
gli angeli
i salvati
le differenze sono importanti
l'importanza sono i gruppi che mostrano
la loro identità è un modo e il modo
classico con noi cerchiamo di diciamo di
costruire l'unità quando noi parliamo
esempio parlo di pubblico di classe di
maschi di femmine e categorie
in cui annulliamo le università e per
cercare di cogliere l'unità
dell'esperienza
quarta strategia separare su più livelli
cose che è difficile mettere insieme
Guardate questo
questo quadro
famosissimo famosissimo di Piero della
Francesca dove ci stanno dei personaggi
sulla destra che sembrano non
concentrarsi non c'entrare niente con
quella flagellazione che sta sulla
sinistra che sta in fondo in questo
spazio reso militare dalla prospettiva
ci sono due eventi diversi e sta
ovviamente a noi che osserviamo cercare
di capire il perché è molto spesso non
ci riusciamo e quando noi facciamo un
discorso per punti e poi dobbiamo
mettere i punti insieme alcune volte ci
riusciamo altre volte non ci riusciamo
bene queste sono le strategie per
cogliere la unità vi faccio vedere a
qualcuno di queste strategie per
cogliere la molteplicità e la ricchezza
e la difformità La prima è questa qua
quella là di di
enfatizzare la specificità se osservate
l'uomo medio che sta al centro e privo
di senso non ci dice chi è se voi Vedete
invece come Modigliani a lungo il collo
di Gianna Guten e come iconcill distorci
il proprio corpo vediamo che
immediatamente
enfatizzando alcuni aspetti
cogliamo un senso vogliamo nel caso del
primo caso la spiritualità di questa
donna che viene trasportata fuori dalla
contingenza quotidiana e dall'altra
parte le tensioni interne eh di
hiroshield Insomma quando noi
utilizziamo gli aggettivi i superlativi
i qualificativi per
stressare il significato della nostra
esperienza facevamo esattamente quello
che fa qui che fanno qui queste due
personaggi seconda strategia della
molteplicità ricombinare Guardate la
Torre Eiffel dal basso fotografata
Guardate come la dipinge della nei la
smonta e la rimonta immediatamente una
cosa che sembrava un po' piatta
acquista slancio acquisto proprio un
senso di verticalità di slancio verso
l'alto vado velocemente
e una terza strategia è quella là di
espandere
espandere diciamo il potere del centro
ed è un maestro qui e Paul Klee perché
vedete assumere un centro un centro di
riferimento un principio un'idea però
non è sufficiente poi bisogna pigliare
questa energia che viene da questo
principio
e poi calarla nella realtà nella pratica
bene dal punto di vista proprio
figurativo
quella energia che che parte da questo
cerchio rosso poi in qualche modo viene
strutturata da questa griglia di case
che c'è sotto Se voi fate la prova
coprendo una parte dell'immagine
comprerete benissimo che i due elementi
sono fondamentali Affinché si genera
un'energia complessiva
Infine un ultimo bellissimo esempio
quello di contrastare equilibrare
guardate questa bellissima ballerina di
Dega che sembra volare Perché sembra
volare perché il decafa questa
operazione
mette un contrappeso visivo che
quell'uomo nero che sta a sinistra che
tira verso in basso quella specie di
bilancio visiva e fa lievitare fra
levitare quell'altra figura quindi la
figura prende vita perché inserisce una
tensione all'interno dell'immagine
un'attenzione visiva è la stessa cosa
che noi facciamo quando
contrastiamo due opinioni per vedere da
questo contrasto se emerge qualcosa di
nuovo bene quello che voglio dirvi è che
queste strategie compositive che usa in
questo caso usano i diciamo i pittori
però utilizzate in tutte le arti servono
per sviluppare la fluidità cognitiva
cioè quella capacità di partire dalle
ipotesi però di riuscire anche a
confutarle e a farne nuove queste questa
capacità di apprendere continuamente per
questa capacità serve la fluidità
cognitiva serve la possibilità di
utilizzare insieme
ambedue queste questi gruppi di
strategie per cui il messaggio finale è
questo che l'arte ci allena a capire la
complessità E sostanzialmente ci allena
alla vita grazie